essence et même le gazole au dessus de 2
euros le litre dans cette station de
nevers les automobilistes font leurs
comptes tu mettais 80 euros de gasoil
quand je sais le plein il ya deux mois
vaut pas la peine ma planche pour max et
ça va être plus de son ombre au moins
sept hausses liées aux conflits en
ukraine intervient après deux mois
d'augmentation plus 23 centimes pour le
gazole depuis noël et d'après michel
edouard leclerc ce matin ça n'est pas
fini il va y avoir une hausse de 10
centimes dans la semaine à peu près dans
toutes les stations ça veut de 8 à 10
centimes dans la semaine chez vous et
ailleurs chez vous dans sa citation de
de france quant au gaz sont courts
s'enflamme plus 60% depuis le début de
la guerre si le robinet russe et coupez
les solutions de repli sont minces la
patronne benjy prévient si nous ne
recevions plus de gaz de russie on
pourrait aussi demander aux français de
baisser leur consommation leur chauffage
baisser le thermostat d'un degré sur une
année représenterait l'équivalent de la
production de deux réacteurs nucléaires
le prix du pain aussi pourrait augmenter
car le cours des céréales est également
à la hausse le prix des énergies grimper
le prix des loyers l'inflation et cetera
grimper le prix des matières premières
agricoles qui représentent une part
certains films dans la baguette montrent
aussi donc tout cela qu'on recule et
peut avoir un impact sur le prix de
notre baguette et donc sur le pouvoir
d'achat des français pas de quoi qu'il
en coûte 7 fois le gouvernement propose
un accompagnement ciblé pour les
particuliers les entreprises qui en ont
le plus besoin